[Music]
beautiful what y'all think mom we love
the shame is in the shape some nice she
looks like she walked out of like a
wedding catalog I'm like oh my gosh this
is stunning
thank you
is there anything you don't like about
it well no disappointments confession
let's go up one to ten what we should
give it and she gave it a I gave it a 10
so then this has to be like D dress I do
want to see the other one oh yeah I want
to see some of the other choices yeah
I really really liked it but I want to
know that I know and I don't feel like I
know that I know with this one I only
have one concern I happen to agree on or
the tie in the wall they all look the
same to me yeah oh my ball gown you
don't have a silk crepe you don't
they're all the exact same feel so you
need to try on something different okay
I'll try and I will I think we should
shake it up a little bit all right
okay you know what do you think well I
was think of this okay all right it's in
the woods it's gonna be very I'm gonna
say fairytale ass I'll say about this
dress
so how beautiful the detail is very
romantic
yes I love it this gown is Lily it's a
really soft ball gown with a textured
floral lace okay that's kind of amazing
yes
Bret is gonna look amazing in this okay
let's do it
okay a ball gown is not really what I
would choose but it's really beautiful I
can tell that it's beautiful I so know
for me I still like that it's tight in
the waist which is actually really
pretty gorgeous oh that's very pretty
I love it it looks magical it looks very
wedding like oh no I almost like this
better I don't know what I'm doing like
I love this also okay so now I'm
completely confused
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]